et de leurs coupes moto sont entrées
seront peu bafouillé d'accord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'évidence non je dirais tout le
savoir-faire de maintien de l'ordre de
la police française ou la gendarmerie
française est connu internationalement
au niveau mondial jusqu'à maintenant les
événements auxquels ils ont à faire face
ont permis à ce que le savoir faire sans
tirer à balles réelles s'exerce le jour
on tire à balles réelles ce ne sera plus
les émeutes ce sera autre chose
[Musique]
non la question d'une sécurité
d'éducation des transports ni économie
etc
on prend ces difficultés réelles bien
réel pour des causes ce ne sont que des
conséquences je pense que dans nos
quartiers et en seine-saint-denis
l'enjeu est avant tout culturelle
voilà nous avons nous accueillons des
populations qui viennent d'air culturel
civilisationnel extrêmement différente
et à qui on n'enseigne pas la réalité de
la vie en société en france et si je
devais résumer mon travail de maire et
et si j'avais une supplique à faire aux
pouvoirs publics
mettons des moyens d'abord pour faire
connaître la france
le cas échéant également pour la faire
respecter et croyez moi après eh bien la
france serait plus facilement et mai
[Musique]
non pour la bonne raison que toutes ces
cités si vous regardez leur histoire
était d'une parfaite mixité sociale et
que ce sont les conditions de vie qui se
sont dégradées au point de faire partir
d'abord les plus solvables
puis tous ceux qui n'en pouvait plus et
ne sont restés que ceux qui étaient pour
des raisons de notamment économiques
assigné à résidence donc l'apartheid
voudrait dire qu'il ya une volonté
d'état non ce n'est pas ça
[Musique]
moi je passerais mon temps à faire
connaître la france
si un certain nombre de piliers de notre
vie en france étaient contestées et bien
à la faire respecter
et croyez moi et je parle d'expérience
de mer pour prendre beaucoup de temps et
il consacrait beaucoup de moyens à faire
connaître la france dans ce qu'elle a de
plus belle de ce qu'il a produit deux de
plus admirable et de plus exemplaires eh
bien on peut changer et les choeurs
changer d intelligence changer les
regards et à ce moment là on s'inscrit
dans une toute autre dynamique qui est
plus d'amitié et non pas de dialectique
que certains essayent de manier sans
cesse pour dresser les uns contre les
autres
là c'est sûr on va à l'échec mais faire
connaître respecter et aimer la france
je pense que c'est davantage aller vers
la concorde
[Musique]